We're going to start today with something that
I know some in my audience don't really want to
accept, but when we deny an
empirical reality, we're really all
the worse off. There's no advantage to denying
an empirical reality, and the empirical reality
is that Joe Biden's approval rating is not good,
and it's actually getting down to where Donald
Trump was at this point in his presidency. And
we're going to talk about why we'll talk about
the implications and we'll talk about what could
be done to reverse it. But it is now very clear
that Joe Biden has a political problem on his
hands, and as a result, Democrats have a political
problem on their hands. In terms of the numbers,
Joe Biden's approval has dropped below 40 percent
for the first time in his presidency, according
to the real clear politics average of polls. Now
what real clear politics does is it takes a number
of different polls individually, some of which
might have a bias. Like, for example, it includes
the Rasmussen poll, which can have sort of a
right wing bias. It includes the IBD Tipp poll,
which some say has a bit of a left wing bias,
etc. And you get an average. And yesterday that
average dropped for the first time below 40 to
thirty nine point eight, and today has recovered
just a sliver to exactly 40. And as you can see,
if you're watching, that's the lowest that
it has been since the start of Joe Biden's
presidency. And if we ask the question,
well, it's common that sometimes presidents
come into office with a higher approval
and then it sort of declines over time.
How does it compare to past presidents?
And FiveThirtyEight does that for us. And
what you see when you look is that Joe Biden came
into office with a significantly higher approval
than Donald Trump, about 10 points higher. And
that has slowly gone down, down down to where
they are now, almost identical at this point
in their presidencies. Biden and Trump are now
basically equal in terms of approval. Joe Biden's
approval is well below where Barack Obama's was at
this point in his presidency. It, because of 911,
is dramatically below where George W. Bush's was,
although George W. Bush did ultimately squander
the high approval that came in the aftermath of
911. Joe Biden's approval, although for a period
of time, was higher than Bill Clinton's. At this
point in his presidency, it has now dropped
below. Biden's approval is well below where
George H.W. Bush's was. It is below where
Ronald Reagan's was. And if we want to go
back further, it is also below where
Jimmy Carter's was similar to Gerald Ford,
well below Richard Nixon. And you know, we could
go back further and and it's a different era if
you go back to LBJ, Kennedy and Eisenhower. It's
a completely different political era altogether.
I don't know how much we get from looking at those
numbers, but the point here is Joe Biden does have
a political problem on his hands now. Why is Joe
Biden's approval so low? It's a combination of
things. First and foremost, it has been some time
since Joe Biden has had what we might consider a
major accomplishment. Relatively early on, Joe
Biden had the COVID stimulus package. Shortly
after that, there was the dramatic rollout of the
accelerated rollout of COVID vaccines. But then
Joe Biden got hit with the Delta variant.
Then Joe Biden left Afghanistan, which I
believe is 110 percent the right decision.
But the right was able to weaponize it
pretty successfully in terms of saying it
was chaotic and mis planned, and it said
all the things that it would have been
under Trump as well. But that hurt Joe Biden
infrastructure was done. But it got
relatively little coverage. And then now
there's sort of this lull. And so I think there's
a couple of different questions that we could ask
one in a vacuum. What could Joe Biden do to
raise his approval in the short term? I did
a tick tock clip about this by by popular demand.
And there's a few different things that Joe Biden
could do in the short term, although I don't
know how much they would benefit him long term.
You know, we've talked about the student loan
forgiveness. There is no doubt that doing some
student loan forgiveness would help Joe Biden's
approval rating in the immediate. But would it
really help him? And would it help Democrats
longer term? Maybe, maybe not. I'm not sure
something on decriminalizing marijuana federally,
I think would be very popular. But could he get
it done? Is sort of a real question. What about
announcing that the pandemic is over and this
question, which just three days
ago was sort of like, Yeah, maybe
it is very clear that. Due to political pressure
and, quite frankly, fatigue with the pandemic,
numerous states are now saying we're getting rid
of masks, we're getting rid of masks in schools,
we're getting rid of, in some
cases, requirements for vaccination
to go to certain types of businesses.
And my expectation is that for political
reasons between now and March 1st, which
is the date of the next state of the Union
that Joe Biden is going to give, I expect it could
be next week. It could be on the day of the State
of the Union sometime between now and March 1st.
I expect the Biden White House to come out and
say we are now at the point where life can really
start going back to normal now. There's divergent
views as I talk to you about yesterday as to
whether that is a scientifically and medically
sound thing to do. Some say there's really no
more milestones to wait for. We don't get a more
deadly variant. It's sort of going to be like this
for the next, however many years. There's really
nothing else to wait for. It's time to go back
to a quote normal and let people make decisions
for themselves about their level of risk. The
counterpoint to that is that there's still a
lot of people dying as a result of the
surge that started a couple of months
ago. It is not the time to do it.
I think that there is significant
leaning right now within the Biden White
House to sometime between now and March 1st,
take a sort of mission accomplished approach,
make a mission accomplished type statement when
it comes to COVID, whether it will end up being
the right thing or not, I don't know. But Joe
Biden does have a political problem on his hands,
and these are some of the things certainly that
when it comes to COVID are are being considered
and very quickly because we're basically eight
and a half months from the midterms. What happens
in the next six weeks is going to set the tone
for what the midterm races are going to
look like in terms of what Republicans will
use to run against Democrats. The culture stuff
for sure. But what else are they going to use?
And there's this limited window
now to set the tone for that,
for what that's going to be. And of
course, we'll be following what it is.